this is 8 news now weekend edition with
sasha loftis sally jaramillo and john
treach 8 news now weekend edition live
local now a victim of a long time las
vegas pimp is sharing what happened
behind closed doors it's a story the
i-team's vanessa murphy has been
following she has this interview you'll
only see here on 8 news now
jamal rasheed also known as malimal is
serving a 33-month prison sentence after
admitting he was a pimp in las vegas for
12 years can 33 months change him
absolutely not angela williams says
rasheed brainwashed her forced her to
sell sex in multiple states and took the
money williams and another survivor have
filed a lawsuit against rasheed and the
state of nevada they allege state
officials perpetuate sex trafficking
they point out prostitution is illegal
in clark county however escort services
are legal which prosecutors say rasheed
used as a front what can you say about
the allegations against you
were you a pimp here in las vegas no
comment to the i-team from rasheed at
his may 13th sentencing the hip-hop
producer is currently at a federal
prison in oregon with a 2023 release
date court records reveal on september
16 he filed for bankruptcy that's
despite photos and videos in recent
years showing a lavish lifestyle in
court documents he reports income at
more than 333 thousand dollars for the
year but claims his expenses put him in
the red williams says while rasheed
lived lavishly she was denied basic
needs 33 months is definitely
a sweetheart deal for all of the victims
and all of the trauma that they faced
through his years of racketeering
traffic sex trafficking
across america
hundreds of women the 46 year old has
worked with musicians including justin
bieber drake and french montana now
williams says she's hoping they'll use
their platforms to speak out i just wish
that
these big artists
these
platinum
winning artists
artist would just stand up
with our community and start a war
against sex trafficking she says
surviving now is a day-to-day choice and
she's sharing her story for those who
may not have the courage
the
emotional trauma and the psychological
trauma that you deal with from ptsd and
coercion and manipulation
last longer than a black eye that gets
healed vanessa murphy live local
now
as the i-team has reported there was an
fbi investigation into possible police
corruption in metro's vice unit that's
the group responsible for investigating
pimp's like rasheed however it appears
rasheed's case is the only one to move
forward sheriff joe lombardo has said
changes were made and the vice unit has
been cleaned up